[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui la paix nous la proposons à tout
moment nous sommes prêts à recevoir les
délégués de ceux qui nous combattent dès
qu'il aura été mis un terme aux ultime
accrochage et attentats le gouvernement
pourra régler avec toutes les tendances
algérienne et notamment avec les
dirigeants de la rébellion
les conditions dans lesquelles aura lieu
au grand jour la libre autodétermination
c'est par là que la réponse positive du
pays au référendum aura aussi le
caractère d'un appel à la fin des
combats et à une pacifique qu'auront
fronta sion françaises français louent
oui franc et massif que vous demande le
général de gaulle président de la
république sera la décision de la france
il offrira à l'algérie la chance d'un
libre à venir il prouvera au monde que
la nation française est aujourd'hui
autant que jamais unis russie est
généreuse
g hallucinant dans le ciel de new york 2
quadrimoteur un dc 8 et 1 constellation
se sont rencontrés en plein vol l'un est
tombé en flammes dans une banlieue
proche
l'autre s'est écrasé dans le quartier
populeux de brooklyn communiquant le feu
à plusieurs immeubles qu'il avait heurté
dans sa chute
collision tragique dont le bilan s'élève
à 142 morts
par miracle la chute l incendie n'ont
fait aucune victime parmi les habitants
des building
mais tous les passagers ont péri les
équipages également c'est la plus
tragique catastrophe aérienne
enregistrée jusqu'ici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
24 heures ne s'étaient pas écoulées
depuis la tragédie de routine une autre
catastrophe aérienne un autre drame
hallucinant en deuxième unique un
bimoteur militaire s'était écrasé en
pleine rue sur un tramway
[Musique]
passagers et équipage usagers du tramway
neil et dans la fournaise 49 nouvelles
victimes à ajouter à celles de brooklyn
la série noire
la fin de sept années 1960 aura donc
apporter à la belgique
l'événement tant attendu celui qui lui
donnait une rave au palais royal dans la
salle du trône le roi baudouin et dounia
fabiola ont accompli le premier acte en
signant le registre de l'état civil
[Musique]
dounia fabiola de mora y aragon était
devenue aux yeux de la loi
la cinquième reine des belges
[Musique]
bruxelles était brumeuse et froide mais
ni le fanny la brume n'ont jamais
empêché une foule heureuse de se presser
sur le passage d'un cortège royal
à plus forte raison ce jour là où la
foule belle je faisais là et jusqu'à la
collégiale sainte gudule
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à sainte gudule le spectacle avait
commencé avec l'arrivée des invités
d'honneur
la reine juliana de allende au gras du
roi olav de norvège
la princesse margaret audra du prince
bertil dessus rc2 vente à partir de rois
et de reines que baudoin et fabiola les
mains enlacées sous les tôles du
cardinal vadrouille prononcèrent le
serment sacramentelle et c'est sous le
regard du roi léopold et de la reine
doit arrière elizabeth
ils échangèrent leurs anneaux
[Musique]
baudouin 1er et fabiola sont maintenant
unis devant dieu comme devant les hommes
unis comme dit le vieil adage pour le
meilleur et pour le pire
le roi et la reine en quittant
sainte-gudule vont retrouver sur le
parvis la foule bruxelloise qui depuis
25 ans attendait le nom de pouvoir à
nouveau crié vive la reine ces cris de
vive la reine devait retentir à travers
bruxelles tout au long de la tournée
triomphale qui conduisait le couple
royal de 5,0 à l'est en particulier sur
la grand place de l'hôtel de ville
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est sans doute au balcon du
palais que le roi et la reine des belges
ont donné la plus belle image de leur
union
puisque dans cette image la foule a pu
lire au delà de l'épisode d'une journée
qui appartient à l'histoire
les pilotes d'une histoire d'amour
[Musique]
une chanson qui n'est une chanson qui
sera demain sur toutes les lèvres
oui et non mais davantage
[Musique]
où
tu vois
rien
que trois grands rois
maria
[Musique]
oui
c'est pour la nuit de noël que gilbert
bécaud à composer l'enfant à l'étoile
cette extraordinaire cantate compte
entendu les premières les voûtes de
saint germain l'auxerrois
[Applaudissements]
cher
[Musique]
ans
le temps là s'il avait su c'est pas moi
qui permet sa porte
comment la ferme à 2 1 s'il avait su
il avait su qu'elle s'était
et lui s'étaient j'en sais il
c'était faux
m
comme la terre
[Musique]
e
fait
les
e
boulogne est à toi
ouais
la vauban
mais
une fois
ce n'est rien
il m'a atteint
trois personnages tueur
il y a
que la grande
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu bois bryas rappellera
l'annoncé qui fâchent
dubois
il y a
entre les mains
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]